Hi! I'm Erik Voss, and the new movie, Baby
Driver, is one of the most thrilling,
entertaining films I've ever seen.
Director Edgar Wright, who also made Shaun
of the Dead and Scott Pilgrim vs. the
World, is one of my favorite filmmakers.
His whole visual style, and the way he
has been increasingly setting his films
to music, with choreographed action scenes
that play out like music videos.
Now with Baby Driver, Wright takes this method to
a whole new level, writing the full 35
song soundtrack into the script, and
letting each song dictate the narrative
of the scene that it's in. Now, this is the
opposite of how music normally works in
films. Traditionally, scenes are written
and shot and edited, and then a composer
composes the score to the scene. He said
he was actually warned by director
Quentin Tarantino not to write the exact
songs into the script before shooting,
because often it's hard for the studio
to secure the rights to use these songs.
But Wright did it anyway. And he blasted
this music over speakers on set, and had
actors and crew people listen to
synchronized ipods. And the end result
is that it all plays out like an action
musical. Like Stomp, but with cars.
Honestly, it feels a lot more like after
you see a Fast and Furious movie, and
you're driving home and some great song
comes over the radio, and then suddenly
you're in a movie, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da,
then you're getting pulled over, and you start
crying because cops intimidate you... So,
let's look at the most interesting
examples of how Edgar Wright uses
specific music to construct a scene in
Baby Driver. And spoiler warning, if you
haven't seen the movie yet. Seriously, go
watch it. Okay, let's start with the
opening images of the film. The music in
this opening heist scene is Bell-Bottoms,
by John Spencer Blues Explosion.
Edgar Wright actually said this song is what
inspired the whole film. Back in the 90s
when he was 21 and broke, he listened to
Bell-Bottoms and noticed how it starts
out with a steady blues riff and then
two minutes in, it explodes into this
frantic garage rock jam. He said how this
shift in the music made him visualize an
entire car chase film scene, and then
years later in 2011, after Wright made a
few movies that were successful, he
directed a music video for Mint Royale
called Blue Song. And he said that that
vision in his head transformed into this
concept of a getaway driver waiting
while a heist goes down, rocking out alone
in a car to the beat of the music, with
the song used as a timer for the heist.
He actually planned for this music video
to be the opening scene of his eventual
film, Baby Driver, and six years later,
that's pretty much what he did. The first
two minutes of Bell Bottoms is the timer
for Buddy, Darling and Griff to rob
the bank. And then when they return, the
music kick arrives and the chase begins,
with each tire screech and police siren
all set to the beat of the music. Now
this synchronization might have reminded
you of the trailers for Suicide Squad,
the way gunfire and punches all
correspond to Bohemian Rhapsody,
However, Wright actually said that this is
even more of a challenge than Suicide
Squad trailers were, because instead of
an editor just matching up shots to
music in an editing bay after the fact,
he did this process on the set, in the
direction of the actors and the stunt
drivers. And yeah, this is way harder, but
Wright did say it also saved money,
because storyboarding each sequence into
sections of a song forced them to think
more mathematically, because then there's
zero-fat when you're shooting it. Like,
the song won't get any longer, so the
stunts have to be exact and stay within
budget. Okay, now let's move on to the
sequence that comes immediately after: a
three-minute tracking shot following
Baby on his morning walk to get coffee,
set to the music of Harlem Shuffle by
Bob and Earl.
Now you may have noticed that this song
starts the same way as House of Pain's
Jump Around.
And that's because House of Pain actually sampled
this exact riff from Harlem Shuffle. And
Wright said that he intentionally wanted
to catch us off-guard like this, and he
does this throughout the film, using more
obscure covers of songs, while in other
cases switching back to the lesser-known
original version. Wright also got British
DJ Mark Nicholson, also known as Osymyso, to compose a new mix of Harlem
Shuffle to blend in audio from
people on the street, footsteps, people
talking, dogs barking, an ATM beeping as
woman punches in her pin, even the actor
Ansel Elgort saying yeah yeah yeah to the beat
of the music. I really have to watch this
movie again, because even the words and
the signs and the graffiti on the walls
sync up to words that you hear in the
song at that moment. The point of all
this is to put us firmly inside Baby's
head. A car accident that he suffered as a
kid left him with a constant ringing sound,
so he's constantly listening to music to
drown it out. So when we go inside his
head, we see that the world around him is
alive with music. It's as if he's
composing all of these sounds into his
own personal life soundtrack, which is
something he literally does later in
this movie. Now, of course, this scene was
carefully choreographed ahead of time.
Wright brought in the choreographer Ryan
Heffington, and he said he walked through
the sequence with an iPhone camera over
and over again to get it precise. The end
result is this amazing sequence that
looks like it could be from a musical
like La La Land. Okay, let's move on to the
next big action sequence, the second
heist in the truck. And the music here is
Neat Neat Neat by the Damned.
Now Edgar Wright sent the script to the
actors along with the thumb drive
containing the soundtrack, and Flea from
the Red Hot Chili Peppers, who plays
Eddie No Nose in this scene, saw this
song, Neat Neat Neat, in the track list, and
that is what sealed the deal for him to
be in the film. And the fun thing about
this song is that it's too short. It's only
about 2 minutes long. So when they were
storyboarding the scene, the
cinematographer of the movie, Bill Pope,
told Wright that they were going to run
out of song. These trucks just couldn't
move as fast as Wright would need them
to to fit within the song. So Wright said
he came up with a creative solution: he
added this shot where they have to
change cars, and Baby refuses to hit the
gas until he resets the song. "Wait wait wait, I gotta
start the song over. Ok, go." And this is
great, because it also tells us more
about Baby as a character. He is that
obsessed with having music playing all
the time, even if it slows him down for a
second. And again, this is discipline by
Edgar Wright. He insisted so hard on having
this music that he crafted the story and
the character around it. And it led to
this great character-revealing moment.
Now, we could probably look at the music
in every scene in Baby Driver like this,
like even Baby meeting Debora in the
diner is structured around Carla
Thomas's Baby and T Rex's Debora and
Beck's Debra. And sure, I would love to dig
into those, but let's stick with the
action and fast-forward to this
warehouse shootout. Now the music here is
Tequila but instead of the popular
Champs version that everyone knows, Wright
again used a cover version, this one by
the Button-Down Brass. Now the middle of
this song features a dueling drum solo,
and when Wright first heard that, he said
that it would be amazing to do a
gunfight scene to that. And because there
was so much gunfire in the scene, it
drowned out all the music playing from
the speakers on set or in the earbuds, so
the choreographer and stunt guy had to
teach each actor the rhythm of the shots.
And then as they repeatedly shot the
scene, they had to keep counting them in,
like 5 6 7 8 bang bang ba-bang. And Wright
said that on one take when he was
checking in with Jamie Foxx to make sure
he had the gunfire rhythm down, Foxx was
walking him through it, saying this guy
goes up ba-ba-ba, and I go ba-ba, and then
he jokingly mimed taking a drag on a
cigarette, and Wright loved that invisible
cigarette so much that he had Foxx do it
for the movie. So yeah, this is
another example of this meticulous
choreography to the music
leading to a really fun, memorable image
that Wright probably wouldn't've had in the
film otherwise. Okay, let's take a look at
one last great example of Wright's use
of music in Baby Driver later in the
movie - the foot chase. The music here is
Focus by Hocus Pocus. God, I love saying that.
Now Wright said that this was his
favorite part of the movie, but that the
studio actually wanted to cut it; they
refused to pay for the scene, but he
wanted the scene so bad that he paid out
of pocket for two extra days of shooting
to film it. Now, Wright said that he first
heard Hocus Pocus on a music show in
England, and that he was blown away by
this progressive rock song that, unlike
most songs, changes tempo throughout the
song. Now, like most songs just have one
tempo that plays all the way through,
which isn't really helpful for film
scoring, since the action changes so fast.
But Wright described Focus as the
perfect cardio track that dictates where
Baby goes. Like fast guitars for when
he's sprinting, and then this yodeling
section for when he's hiding behind a
tree, and then another shift when he's
running through the mall, and then an
accordion section when he breaks into a
car. Now these were just the big examples
of creative music editing that stood out
to me, but what was your favorite musical
moment in Baby Driver? Also, are there any
other movies or TV shows that you think
would have benefited from this approach
of letting music dictate the story?
Really, there is so much going on in Baby
Driver, and I would love to do a full
breakdown of all the missable stuff
that I caught, but really, just more
people need to go see this movie, and you
can help get the word out by sharing
this video,
liking it, and tweeting with links to
this video and your favorite thing about
Baby Driver. You can hit me up on twitter
directly (@eavoss) or follow new
rockstars on twitter (@newrockstars)
and of course subscribe to this channel
for all of our videos about film
analysis and music in cinema. We've done
this kind of stuff for the Wonder Woman
theme song, Game of Thrones, and the
soundtrack for Guardians of the Galaxy, so
look around, I think you'll like a lot of
stuff here. And if you really want to be
part of this channel and help us decide
what kind of videos to make, you can
contribute to us on patreon. Thank you so
much to all of our current donors,
especially Chris Kell. All the best to you
and your Baby Driver on the way. Congrats,
buddy.
Okay, thanks for watching, and Edgar
Wright, if you're watching this, I have a
script that I would love for you to look
at.